[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dodo l'enfant do l'enfant dormir a bien
vite
dodo l'enfant do l'enfant dormir à
bientôt
on connaît tous cette chanson
automatiquement elle nous bascule vers
notre époque elle est douce à lombers
pour beaucoup d'entre nous c'est une des
premières chansons que nous avons
entendu ces notes résonnent encore avec
la voix de nous par an cette chanson que
nous connaissons tous nous la chanson
aujourd'hui nous lâcheront demain à nos
enfants mais avant de la susurrer à
l'oreille de nos chères petites têtes
blondes nous avons d'abord chanter et
danser seul sur le chemin de la vis et
puis un jour on a choisi et décidé de
chanter de danser à deux c'est quand
même beaucoup plus joyeux et comme on
maîtrise bien la chanson ad'autant on
s'emballe et on passe à trois temps on
saute alors à pieds joints dans le monde
des grands et on devient à notre tour
par an
on entre alors dans un nouveau monde est
dans une nouvelle ronde et avec cette
nouvelle chanson de grands on se
retrouve petit à petit devant
l'immensité du petit
et l'homme se transforme alors en papa
papa
quatre lettres
la simple le papa si jusqu'à plâtre non
mais c'est vrai les sujets compliqués
sont faits de plaint de maux auxquels on
comprend pas forcément grand chose par
exemple pour vous parler de paternité
j'aurais aussi pu vous dire
l'activisme nous confère une envie
donald oji descendante reconductible
poussé par l'envi de filiation à la
manière de la théogonie
on est d'accord on n'y comprend rien
bah pas c'est simple alors ça va être
d'être papa mais non c'est pas si simple
d'être papa c'est un tsunami alors c'est
un tsunami d'émotion de joie de bonheur
bien sûr mais aussi de peur et de
changement c'est un tsunami qui s'abat
sur nos petites routes de vie tranquille
en seulement quelques instants on doit
apprendre à surfer sur la vague et
éviter de boire la tasse
on doit apprendre les paroles d'une
nouvelle chanson et tout faire pour
éviter les fausses notes
cette nouvelle chanson je l'aï apprise à
36 ans et je l' ai même entendu en
stéréo puisque je suis devenu papa de
jumeaux zory élus louf j'ai aussi eu la
chance d'entendre une toute petite
chanson sur mon chemin avant de avant de
devenir papa pour faire simple cette
chanson elle me disait que en devenant
papa tout allait changer dans ma vie
alors j'ai décidé de tout changer je
suis passé de la caricature du cadre sup
toujours entre deux trains et deux
avions à l'homme heureux et épanoui dans
son job est dans son rôle de père j'ai
changé une très forte rémunération est
un très bon statut social contre du
temps et du sens
j'ai osé changer de vie pro en devenant
papa à ce moment de vie où la société
impose de la norme et de la sécurité
j'ai vu moi l'opportunité d'écrire une
toute nouvelle page de vie aussi bien
pour ma vie pro que pour ma vie perso
j'ai décidé d'oser
j'ai ainsi pu passer beaucoup de temps
et c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui avec
mes enfants
les premières années à sont
fondamentales dans leur construction
c'est le moment on leur apporte la
sécurité affective et émotionnelle dont
ils ont besoin pour bien grandir et
c'est le moment où l'on construit avec
eux leurs justes estime de soi et
confiance en soi dont ils auront besoin
demain en tant qu'adulte
mais j'ai aussi vite compris que le
disque de la chanson pouvait se grippe
et
que la chance on pouvait même s'arrêter
net sans aller jusqu'à ses dernières
notes
mes enfants sont nés très prématuré à
sept morts
s'en sont suivis deux mois non-stop à 4
à l'hôpital une vie en suspens entre
parenthèses dans une bulle
mais où sont des bips des machines
reliées au coeur de nos enfants
puis aux six mois de ma fille nous avons
dû lui faire subir une opération très
lourde une opération à coeur ouvert
alors aujourd'hui ils vont en avoir cinq
ans ils sont en pleine forme
mais débuter ta chanson de papa sur ses
notes te fait forcément réfléchir et
quelques semaines après ces différents
événements j'ai décidé que je n'aurai
plus jamais peur de toujours osé et
d'aider les gens à aux êtres libres à
leur tour
aujourd'hui je suis ce que l'on appelle
un slasher j'ai plusieurs activités
alors je suis papa ça je crois que vous
l'avez bien compris slash je suis
consultant en communication et
management slash intervenant en école
supérieure slash conférencier blogueurs
et formateur en parentalité est en
équilibre de vie et toute l'année
dernière je me suis engagé avec un
collectif de papa sur l'augmentation de
la durée du congé paternité en france
parce que c'est un combat essentiel à
mon coeur mais c'est un combat
fondamental pour toutes les femmes pour
tous les hommes pour tous les enfants
bref pour toutes les familles et la
société dans sa globalité
j'écris chaque jour une nouvelle
partition pour la chanson de ma vie je
préserve beaucoup de temps pour mes
enfants tout temps mais pas nous hissant
dans mon job et j'ai d'ailleurs la
chance de ne pas vraiment avoir
l'impression de travail
alors finalement ça va facile d'être
papa
pas tant que ça pas tant que ça à mieux
écouter la chanson qui nous disent ce
que doit être un papa oui cette chanson
que l'on connaît depuis des siècles
cette chanson que l'on a apprise par
coeur sans même s'en rendre compte cette
chanson qui est porté par de trop
nombreuses petites voix parfois soi même
sa famille ses amis ses collègues
certains managers certaines entreprises
certains médias certains politiques
certains livres même et qui nous disent
en gros bacs à la parentalité et surtout
une histoire de ballon que l'homme non
il n'y a pas du tout sa place
le rôle du père c'est quoi c'est de
rapporter la sécurité financière à la
famille moueix un petit peu comme à la
préhistoire quand même c'est d'inventer
le gibier dans la grotte on en est là
dans cette chanson de papa que l'on
connaît depuis des siècles on y parle de
force de travail de sécurité
virilité même
et cela ne sonne pas super bien avec ce
que l'on imagine être un papa
aujourd'hui
et si nous décidions d'écrire une
nouvelle chanson et si nous décidions
d'inventer de nouvelles paroles de mais
trop loin ses injonctions d'un autre
temps de casser le rythme trop lourd de
cette chanson trop entendu et si nous
osions être le papa que l'on a vraiment
envie d'être
car finalement la parentalité c'est le
moment où on se réinvente ces moments
ont construit le monde de demain au
travers de l'éducation quand on partage
avec nos enfants alors oui quand on
devient papa c'est le moment d'être soit
vraiment soir alors osons être soi osons
être soit loin des clichés loin des
stéréotypes
osons être libre osons réinventer sa vie
d'homme et de papa
j'ai la profonde conviction que la force
de l'être humain et dans son unicité que
son épanouissement personnel nourrit sa
vie professionnelle et que sa vie
professionnelle nourrit sa vie
personnelle
que les soft skills que l'on développe
dans sa vie personnelle sont utiles dans
son job et bien sûr vice et versa
depuis la naissance de mes enfants vous
l'avez compris je passe beaucoup de
temps avec eux j'adore jouer avec eux
leur faire découvrir le monde observer
leur regard sur le monde et grâce à eux
j'ai développé depuis cinq ans tout un
tas de compétences qui me sont très
utiles dans le monde job la patience je
rappelle j'ai des jumeaux la patience
donc l'empathie la créativité
l'organisation l'anticipation toutes ces
softs elles viennent de mes enfants
elles ne sont précieuses au quotidien
mon job alors oui j'ai la profonde
conviction que nous pouvons écrire une
seule et même partition pour la chanson
de notre vie
quand on devient parent on se démembre
élise
mais là où depuis des siècles les femmes
devenues mamans osé accepté ce
changement les hommes devenus papas
resté bloqué dans un schéma patriarcale
imposée par la société
mais ça c'était tir car rejoint de plus
en plus d'hommes s'ouvre et au se
remettre en question car ils comprennent
que la parentalité et donc y compris la
paternité est au coeur de la
construction du monde de demain
prenons quelques sujets qui nous anime
aujourd'hui et qui sont fondateurs du
monde de demain et voyons comment la
parentalité il joue un rôle majeur
premier sujet l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes
aujourd'hui en france les femmes gagnent
en moyenne 20 % de moins que les hommes
pour le même job et à compétences égales
et on le sait les études le démontrent
c'est au nom de la maternité que le
décrochage de rémunération se fait
et vous accepteriez vous demain que
votre fille vienne 20 % de moins que ses
collègues juste parce que c'est une
femme
deuxième sujet l'ouverture à la
différence nous sommes tous différents
deux sexes de sexualité d'origine de
religion de culture d'éducation de
croyance et c'est une richesse
incroyable
pourtant
l'intolérance est palpable partout
et vous accepteriez vous demande que
votre fils soit pointé du doigt parce
qu'il est différent
troisième sujet l'équilibré entre la vie
professionnelle et la vie personnelle
c'est avec le sens au travail le premier
vecteur de choix de la nouvelle
génération pour trouver un job et c'est
un enjeu majeur pour les entreprises
aujourd'hui et demain pour attirer et
fidéliser ses talents
et vous accepteriez vous demande de
consacrer tout votre temps et toute
votre énergie à votre travail en passant
à côté de votre vie de famille
dernier sujet l'écologie l'impact que
l'on a sur la terre est complètement
différent au moment même où l'on devient
parent
et vous accepteriez vous demande de
laisser une planète abîmé à vos enfants
on le voit au travers de ces quatre
exemples qui sont tous des sujets
sociétaux fondamentaux comment la
parentalité il joue un rôle majeur et la
chanson de ce que doit être un papa que
l'on connaît depuis des siècles
commencent à évoluer face à des prises
de conscience de plus en plus nombreuses
oui
oui il existe encore de tempo à cette
chanson
alors oui il ya comme moi des hommes qui
osera inventer leurs chansons de vie en
devenant papa je pense à elle papa d'un
bébé prématuré qui suite à la naissance
de son fils a créé une entreprise
citoyenne et responsable pour
accompagner les parents d'enfants
prématurés
je pense à gabriel ingénieurs gabriel il
voulait devenir manager mais son
entreprise estimé qu'il n'avait pas les
compétences à la naissance de sa fille
il prend un congé parental de cinq mois
et quelques semaines après son retour au
travail donc après l'es5 mans il est
nommé manager parce qu'il avait
développé les compétences nécessaires à
cette fonction en étant engagés et
impliqués auprès de sa fille durant cinq
mois
mais je pense aussi à greg chef de rang
qui lui n'a pas osé demander son congé
paternité de peur d'être jugé est mal
perçue par ses collègues et par ses
responsables
où je pense à damien consultants qui lui
s'est fait refuser son congé paternité
et qui n'a ainsi pas pu être auprès de
sa fille et de sa femme qui en avait
besoin
et enfin je pense à grégory dont nous
avons beaucoup parlé ces dernières
semaines grégory les agriculteurs et
père de trois enfants dont des jumeaux
en bas âge il décide de prendre un congé
parental d'un an ce qui est autorisé par
la loi suite à cela il se fait
littéralement harcelé durant sept mois
par son employeur on lui tient des
propos d'un autre temps on lui dit que
c'est un feignant un bon à rien que
c'est un frein pour le développement la
société que sa place n'est pas d'être
près de ses enfants que ça c'est le rôle
de la maman
[Musique]
alors aujourd'hui il ne s'agit surtout
pas d'écrire les paroles d'une seule et
unique chanson il s'agit de casser les
silences de libérer les paroles de
libérer l'audace libérez-le envie d'être
libre libre d'être le papa que l'on a
vraiment envie d'être
la place des pères dans la société et la
faire de tous de chaque homme de chaque
femme des entreprises qui ont un rôle
majeur à jouer sur le sujet des
politiques des médias des écoles
supérieures
il n'existe pas un seul et unique modèle
de papa il n'existe pas une seule vérité
c'est à chacun de créer sa vérité c'est
à chacun de créer sa chanson papa en
fonction de ce dont il a vraiment
devenir papa est un bonheur immense ne
passons pas à côté de ces moments si
précieux il n'existe pas la vie
professionnelle d'un côté la vie
personnelle de l'autre il existe juste
la vis nous pouvons les concilier nous
pouvons choisir de les concilier nous
pouvons choisir de ne pas choisir
nous sommes des acteurs de nos vies
alors osons écrire notre chanson papa et
osons construire notre chemin de papa
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]